i just had a major meltdown oh really
i'm okay now
gary made a mistake he booked jewel
and uh and uh jenny mccarthy at the
exact same time oh no
yeah for eight o'clock whoever gets here
first
i'll tell the other one to go home he
said no you can't do that
wait what did you say it was the best
one
oh whoever gets here first will put on
gary i suppose you could write a note to
them explaining yourself
not an email
all right hi john you're on the air in
philadelphia oh thank you for taking my
phone
yeah so we will have jewel today for
those of you who were excited about
jenny mccarthy coming in she will not be
in because
whoever gets here first will put on the
air just so you know
it's not the smartest thing but it's not
what i meant what i meant was whoever
gets here first we'll put on and then
we'll put the other one
on after after so what am i going to do
the shuttle noon well
but i mean i want i got a life too you
know i was trying to make the best of
the worst i wasn't implying that we'd
send somebody home
oh so like in other words i'd interview
someone at eight o'clock and then at
nine o'clock we can do the second
interview
or eight eight maybe somebody a quarter
to eight somebody at 8 30. all right
that's what it was my
but i was not implying to send anybody
home howard i see
well he's got a point all right good
point send him home howard
gary can i send you home man you can do
whatever you want to me
god's done enough to you what i want to
call in because i was listening to the
wrap-up show
right and i listened to them berated i i
tell you the truth john i'm zoning out
because
i'm so still thinking about that jenny
mccarthy what
i have to call back like right away but
i got to get out of 10. i understand
yeah robin i i would have to do some
sort of news now i'm just trying to
understand
i'm getting the things pulled down i
could get jenny to get here by 8 30
you know so that she nine would be the
latest you'd get on it maybe quarter to
nine because if jewel got here a little
early
yeah you could get it right on but i
have to make that call immediately all
right go ahead and make the call rob and
i will do a little abbreviated news now
i really want to yell at him but i'm
like real i'm fighting the urge
it's like killing me i can't even think
of anything else the great guest race